Around a hundred years ago something really exciting was happening
An age old philosophical question what is the limit
of knowledge collided with the modern mathematical one
can knowledge be mechanised
And this gave birth to a new field
Computer science
the science of computation
The dream of mechanising human knowledge
was inspired by developments over 300 years ago
during the early stages of the industrial revolution
Factories were being developed as industrialists began to explore mass production
and the mechanisation of labour
gradually machines were designed to replicate human action
but replicating human mental processes
remained the stuff of dreams
And this began to change with the development of machines that could add
multiply and eventually make decisions
At first even the most advanced machines were limited to
one specific task
if you needed something else done
you had to build a new machine
However around two hundred years ago
a great industrialist thinker Charles Babbage
was dreaming of a general symbolic machine
one that could answer complex questions
by breaking them down into smaller questions of logic & arithmetic
and essentially braiding them together
His final dream was never realized but
his driving question remained
was it possible to build a general machine
that could answer any question
Now by the 1900s mathematicians and philosophers
were posing this question in different ways
mathematicians asked
what are mechanical machines capable of
how powerful could they be
while philosophers asked
what are the limitations of mechanical machines
what will machines never do
And in 1936 Alan Turing bridged this divide
with a paper which revolutionized our understanding
about what machines can and cannot do
He outlined blueprints for what he called a universal machine
a machine that could answer anything
that was answerable
Part of his great insight was that
the power of the universal machine would always
reside in the instructions it followed
later known as software
not the physical design of the machine
or hardware
And using a simple language
his machine would run any instructions that you could imagine
And the year after Turing's paper a young Claude Shannon
completed a master's thesis describing a clever insight
he had about telephone relays
He realised he could arrange electrical switches
in various ways to perform the fundamental operations of logic automatically
using electricity
Suddenly it was practically possible to build the universal computer
powered by electrical clocks that buzzed away at near the speed of light
and followed any instructions you provide
In the decades to follow computing machines grew and their speed
of operation & memory capacity
Suddenly many hard questions humans faced became easy or very practical
for computers to answer quickly
But deeper problems emerged
There seemed to be a growing set of seemingly easy problems
such as is a given number prime
that were computable on our machines
but took so long when the questions were large
such as is 140 trillion trillion trillion + 1 prime
that it could take thousands or even millions of years
for the computer to give you an answer
or halt
So these problems were practically impossible to solve
think of these as hard problems
and people considered drawing a line in the sand between problems that were easy
practical to solve
and problems that were hard
practically impossible to solve
And the attempt to precisely define this division
of easy and hard, practical and impractical problems
leads to the most important unsolved question in computer science today
what makes hard problems hard ?
Is it a result of some underlying mathematical pattern
or is the perception of hardness merely an illusion ?
will new insights make these hard problems easy ?
And this question is just not an intellectual curiosity
the backbone of the internet depends on a set of problems
being out of reach or practically impossible
for our machines
But to begin we must go
way back in time
and revisit the mythology of ancient oracles
first of all explore what knowledge is
and what it means to think
or to compute